foreign
Jane joins us up next in Lawton Oklahoma
Jane welcome to the show
Hi how are you we're doing great how can
we help you today
oh okay so this is tough
talk in the bank account
I understood his reservations
I do have a full-time job all right
um and a couple of months ago I thought
well maybe I really do need to learn to
manage my finances better because
according to him like I haven't proven
that I know how to manage money
and I started listening to the Dave
Ramsey Show because I thought that you
know I knew of the Ramsay Network and I
have realized that my problems are a lot
more intense than I real than than just
a financial disagreement or a
communication issue
oh
um
you know he's gone half of the time with
his job and he doesn't leave he will not
give me money for groceries any
Necessities
um anytime I bring that up he tells me I
need to manage my money better do you
have a debit card
do I have a debit card yeah how much
money like control and access does he
give you to money
oh zero so you can't spend a dime if you
even wanted to
no I mean I have my like my paycheck but
that's it okay and you're working
full-time
yes do you have any kids I mean I have
one daughter how old is she
uh ten okay is he the dad
no okay
um
all right
are you safe
yeah
I mean physically yes
uh I
all right I'm gonna trust you the the
data suggests that guys who act like
this are
uh physically abusive as well
and I would even go as far to say maybe
hasn't thrown a punch but has created a
world
that is so unsafe for your body that it
shuts itself down and tries to get small
because there's a bear living in that
house
yeah I mean I I've been through some
pretty traumatic things in my life but
like on paper that would be way worse
than this I've never had a panic attack
until recently so I know like full on
like panic attack okay
and I know like I'm educated enough to
know that like your body starts to do
things when it's trying to get your
attention yeah right so what's keeping
you there
well I mean I do I mean I did make a vow
to him
and I take that seriously but I mean I
have a couple of thousand dollars in
debt now that I didn't have before
because I have to put gas and groceries
on credit cards sometimes
he makes about four times what I do sure
I don't want to weave this back and
forth into a finance situation than out
of a finance situation urine is
extremely toxic environment
you're in an unsafe environment and if
we haven't crossed lines yet we will at
some point
and when even when the way you started
the call he told me I haven't proven my
like just those words alone let me know
this is very much a father-daughter
relationship far far more than it's a
husband and wife creating a future
together
right I mean
he I mean if he he does control
everything I mean not just money and if
something's not up to none the way he
wants it done I mean he will threaten to
put me out
why are you I mean trivial stuff like
that's not besides the vow which I mean
this doesn't sound like a marriage if
you just talk hearing you say this out
loud just sounds like toxic roommate
situation
what is he actually signing up for when
he signed up for this marriage
I have recently asked him that and I
mean he's like well I married you
because I love you but Is This Love
I don't think love should feel like this
it does not this is control this is
power
and I I this is this is I'm speaking on
behalf of John deloney not on behalf of
the Ramsay Network here and so
um I I take a much broader view of the
word fidelity
I think you can cheat on somebody and
never sleep with another person but if
you steal from somebody their dignity
and their autonomy and their ability to
have feelings and thoughts and a and a
uh partnership in a relationship that's
not Fidelity right you are cheating that
person out of their life
you're cheating that person out of
connection okay and so I take a much
broader view I think and some people are
very narrow like you got to have sex
with somebody else otherwise it's not
cheating I I I have a much broader view
than that but I'm listening to my sister
Jane here
and you're slowly drowning and you know
it and your body's trying to get your
attention and so I guess what George and
I are asking you
um two guys who love our wives and we're
not perfect man but
I I I'm I'm trying to sit across the
table from you and say why are you what
are you doing why are you here why are
you staying what's the hook
you got a couple thousand dollars who
cares
you're too tough and resilient and brave
you'll have that paid off in no time
like something else is here like what's
the hook why are we staying
I mean I don't know that I could
well I mean some of it's
and I I don't think you're being allowed
to give your all because the person
you're connected to is saying I you can
take your all and flush it down the
toilet
go make the bed the right way
yeah are you scared to leave what would
be the repercussions if you said hey I'm
out
I mean
I mean I just want to stabilize for my
child
this is not it
your child is absorbing
top to bottom what love looks like what
marriage looks like
what uh equality looks like
absorbing it in into their DNA
now I I will never unless somebody is
being physically like assaulted I'm not
going to tell somebody they have they
need to leave their marriage
I've often told people you need to get
to where you are safe and we may need to
take a structured 30-day break
I'm gonna go move in with a friend for
30 days we're going to be very clear on
when I come when I come back with the
conditions of coming back are going to
be but
um and again you're you and I you've got
to make this Choice you're you're an
adult I don't see that going over well
do you see your current situation going
over well
well I mean I probably wouldn't have
reached out to you guys I know I know I
know
um and I hope you hear that we love you
I'm worried about neither options are
easy let's just make that very clear
staying is really hard and leaving is
going to be hard but one leads you to
where you're free
and that your daughter's safe and you're
safe and you can get to a better place
financially instead of living in this
prison
and we just want what's best for Jane
yeah
I mean I'm I'm scared to make a decision
and
um
do you have people who that you know and
trust that can sit with you and hear the
the entirety of the story
yeah a little bit have you opened up do
they know
yeah
what do they tell you
to leave okay
if your friend was in the situation what
would you tell her
I mean I I never imagined myself in this
situation
um no that's what makes these abusive
situations so surreal because it's like
there's no way that's happening I I've
heard that over and over that there's no
way this is happening to me and it may
even be in your case happening again
right
yeah I've never experienced anything
quite like this
um
but I'm just scared of I I'm I'm really
just I don't know what I mean I know
what I need to do
but here's what I want you to do I want
you to reach out to a couple of friends
to reach out to a local counselor in
your community not to go quote unquote
get well right now but you need someone
that's going to walk alongside you as
you have a very challenging road ahead
of you whether you stay and try to
figure out how to make this thing work
or you decide to create an alternative
life outside of this relationship but
listen you're worth being well if you
are tuning in the last segment we talked
to Jane in Oklahoma going through a
really dark financially abusive
situation and just wanted to update you
guys that we have connected her with one
of our in-house Financial coaches that
can walk with her for an extended period
of time and make sure that she's okay
but I know I also has some some direct
inroads to some
resources there in their local community
um
my heart my heart's broken for her so